هي لا تتعلق بعمر بل هي عمليه تراكميه
وليست عمليه راديكاليه سريعه بتعبير
السياسيين تاتيك هكذا وانا بالمناسبه لا
احتفي باي تغيير سريع انا احتفل كثيرا
بالتغيير المتدرج للمدعى للرسوخ المرحله
الملكيه هي مرحله جميله ولو انني انا انا
وانا من كتبته هذا المقال وصلت الى ما
كتبته الى صفحتي الملائكه لكن الانسان لا
بد ان يكون يعني على اقل على علاقه يكون
لديه توجه خالد اخي خالد العمر قصير وليس
همه بلوفه في هذه الحياه فيجب ان تجتهد في
ان تحيا لا ان تعيش اجمل ما امكنك ما
امكنك والحياه وتعتمد على جوده افكالك ولا
تعتمد بحاله من الاحوال على جوده ظروفك
وان نعطيها قليلا بس قليل من الاهميه لكن
جوده الافكار هي هي هي اللي تعطي الانسان
والصفات اللي يصل الى هذه المرحله خليني
اسالك انت وصلت لمرحله الملكيه حول
والحمايه ثم اخرج منه بين همم يعني اقبالا
وادبار كما قلت شوف اهم شيء في الحياه انه
نمو العقلي في خالد ليس كنمو الجسد نمو
الجسد ينمو بشكل لا ارادي لكن الانسان
لابد ان يمارس سلوكا اراديا في التعامل مع
الخبرات مع المواقف الكثير ويمر عليه كثير
من الخبرات وكثير من المواقف لكن هناك من
لا يستفيد لذلك المرحله الملكيه تحتاج
اليك ان تعمل العقل هذا اولا امرا اخر في
غايه الاهميه العمر قصير هل ستخضع لمساله
التجربه والخطا لا طبعا لذلك قضيه
الاحتكاك بالعقلاء والناضجين والحكماء
والقراءه والاطلاع لا شك انه يعجل بالوصول
الى هذه المرحله من اخر الاشياء التي
توصلت اليها في هذه المرحله
من 60% اعطوني 60 70% اخذوا ما تيسر منهم
30 انا محللهم وهذا ايضا ينطبق على نفسي
لا اطالب ونفسي بان اعطي بنسبه 100% ابدا
ولا طالب 60 70% احد
ظاهر المرحله الملكيه ايضا في المرحله
الملكيه بالمناسبه خالد خلصت من وهم
السيطره انا كان جاتني مرحله معينه كنت
اعتقد ان المسؤول عن كل شيء عن تغيير
الاخرين عن تغيير الطباعهم عن بعض الاشياء
التي تزعجني لا لا لا لا الان وصلت الى
مرحله فيها اعتقد يعني احسب ان فيها شيئا
من النظري انني بدات اميز او بدات يعني
اعرفه دائره مسؤولياتي
في المرحله يعني
ليست تغيير الاخرين
يسووك عندهم بعض الاشياء وبعض الطباعه
وبعض العادات وكنت اعتقد انني انا المسؤول
عنهم وكنت الوهم نفسي واصل الى درجه الجلد
الذات لي وضعي لكن اكتشفته مؤخرا ان ان
مسؤوليه تتظل محدوده ليه مسؤوليتي محدوده
والله
اعتقد حتى يعني من باب التوسع واحنا حتى
حتى الرحله الطيران او تاخرت ليش ليش ليش
ليش تاخرت كثير
لكن الحمد لله ههه
في تغيير في النفسيه بفضل ايش بفضل تغيير
الافكار لن تتغير حياتك الا اذا تغيرت
افكارك انشتاين له كلمه جميله دائما يتحدث
عنها وهي منهج حياه يقول ان عقلك الذي
انتج مشكله معينه بنفس المستوى من العقليه
او من الوعي ما راح يحلها تحتاج الى ادوات
جديده وهذه الادوات انما تاتيك الغالب من
الافكار الجديده او او من التخلي من افكار
قديمه